hey 42 here Google was founded on the
4th of September 1998 and for most of
that time Google com has been the most
trafficked website in the world although
it has faced stiff competition from
websites like Facebook in recent years
it still remains the number one most
visited web site the amount of searches
Google processes every day is
mind-boggling in 2012 people made a
total of 1 trillion 873 billion 910
million Google searches that's an
average of 5 billion
134 million searches per day or 50 9421
searches per second
yet Google manages to return each one of
these search results in about 300
milliseconds and Google spends over 4
billion dollars on new data centers
unser vers every year it's easy to think
that not much really happens when you
type something into Google but just to
Google searches produces the same amount
of carbon dioxide as boiling a kettle
but Google isn't just a search engine
Google provides over 100 different
products on services including Google
Mail Translate maps play Drive analytics
blogger and many many more oh and don't
forget YouTube which Google bought for a
measly 1.65 billion dollars in 2006
commonly searched terms are cached this
means Google doesn't have to recalculate
the results every time it's searched and
Google can serve the results
instantaneously to the user however
every day 15% of searches have never
before been typed into the search engine
that's 500 million searches every day
that Google has never seen before and
it's always been that way for the 15
years the company has existed
surprisingly the amount of new searches
has never really dropped brands new
searches like this take up a lot more
processing power and take considerably
longer to render the results because
everything
to be calculated from scratch so to
combat this Google recently added a new
product to its surge called knowledge
graph knowledge graph is a vast database
which holds copious amount of data on a
wide range of entities such as people
places and events it also observes the
connections between them similar to the
human brain this allows Google to
present you of answers not just a list
of links you can see this in action by
asking Google questions such as what is
the speed of light what if Google is so
advanced why is their homepage so basic
it's because the Google founders Larry
Page on Sergey Brin didn't know HTML and
they just wanted a quick interface in
fact for a long time there was no submit
button and the only way to kickstart
your Google search was by pressing the
return key
due to this parsons of the homepage an
early user test they noticed people were
just sitting around after minute of
nothingness the researcher asked what's
up to which they replied we're waiting
for the rest of it so to counter this
the Google copyright message was added
to act as a crude end of page marker but
how did the name Google come about well
it was actually an accident the founders
were going for Google which is a 1
followed by a hundred zeros however they
must felt it Google the I'm feeling
lucky button which takes users straight
to the first search result is nearly
never used however they found removing
it somehow reduces to Google experience
the button is estimated to cost Google
around a hundred million dollars in lost
advertising revenue every year one of
Google's most successful features is the
did you mean spelling corrector when
implemented it instantly doubled their
traffic Google has the largest network
of translators in the world Google is
constantly developing new features but
before a feature is released to the
entire Google user base it is tested on
a small percentage and the results are
closely monitored at least 20% of people
have to use a feature or it will be
scrapped
unlike many large corporations email
in Google isn't fruitless Google
actively listens to feedback
speaking of email Gmail was used
internally for two years before it's
launched the public until recently all
Google employees were encouraged to
spend 20% of their time at work working
on their own projects this innovative
management technique gave rise to some
of Google's biggest projects including
Adsense Gmail Google transit Google News
and Google Talk some core Google
services recently went down for five
minutes which caused worldwide Internet
traffic to drop off by an enormous 40
percent new Google employees are called
new gel's they are initiated by having
to wear a propeller beanie cap on their
first Friday Google loves food the first
chef that Google employed earned twenty
six million dollars from his stock
options the Google headquarters aptly
named the Googleplex has 18 cafeterias
on campus with diverse menus what's more
every Google employee is provided with
free restaurant quality breakfast lunch
and dinner including drinks working at
Google comes with an array of free
benefits including on-site gyms and
daycare there's also a complimentary
concierge service to assist with
everyday tasks the Googleplex is also
fitted out with laundry rooms two
swimming pools unfree beach volleyball
courts as well as some bizarre
installations such as a gigantic t-rex
skeleton a scale replica of spaceship
one enormous android themed models
Google colored phone boxes and adult
sized ball pits Google employees can
give their co-workers massage credits
for a job well done on a project they
can redeem these credit for a free
one-hour massage on campus every Friday
employees can relax and socialize with
free beer and wine Google employees
receive incredible death benefits when a
Googler passes away their surviving
spouse continues to receive half of
their salary for
next ten years as well as $1,000 a month
for each of the Google as children and
finally Google's first ever tweet in
February 2009 looks like this which when
translated from binary code reads I'm
feeling lucky thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you